you know I realize this is the wrong
hand it should be on the left hand it's
this mitten is completely not screen
accurate all right so this is my
Avengers infinity war spoiler talk sorry
it's a little latest one to give
everyone enough time to watch the movie
before I spoil their foreheads
completely not true no I've been sick as
[ __ ] I've been really ill like the
plague kind of stuff and I've been ill I
would have had this thing up Friday
morning as it is here it is so if I seem
a little low energy in here it's not
because I'm not you know excited it's
that I actually am low-energy and
feverish and horse and I'm coughing
among every jump-cut but I love it and
this isn't gonna be a super involved I'm
not gonna go beat by beat through the
movie [ __ ] I saw this movie on Tuesday
I've literally been bedridden for a few
days I think the nyquil has wiped away
most of dude nyquil terrible don't ever
taken fever dreams are bad nyquil dreams
are worse and that is a solid spoiler
warning if you haven't seen Avengers
infinity war please you probably
shouldn't watch this a lot of people
have seen it by now so I think you
probably say but if you have seen it or
you don't care about spoilers welcome
let's just talk about spoiler so first
of all let's talk about some spoilers
break the fourth wall into our world and
talk about spoilers hot toys I'm looking
at you I love those hot toys six scale
collectibles the thing about hot toys
those hot toys are pretty screen
accurate generally speaking if the hot
toys has something that means they have
it in the movie and they're usually
pretty good at hiding spoilers for the
force awakens for the REA preorder they
actually didn't show the fact that array
was going to come with a lightsaber
until after the movie came out I thought
that was a swell move before Avengers
infinity war came out they have their
Thanos pre-order and there you go every
infinity stone in the gauntlet is just
at that point I was like yeah so he gets
all the stones like they're still gonna
stop him right like that's that's
superhero movie 101 yeah we'll get there
so Thanos is intro in this movie I
thought was a great intro for Thanos
though I do have a problem with what
happened with all right here we go it
starts out Thanos is on the Asgardian
ship with all the Asgardian survivors
make it one survive they're all dead now
kills Heimdall so Heimdall's death which
is great in showing that fan OHS can not
be stopped I mean from this scene you
see that he is a force to be reckoned
with this dude is more powerful than
anything we've seen however I do run
into the thing like between aliens and
alien 3 I've always had a problem with
how alien 3 started / how
right you see aliens Ripley goes in
literally into the heart of the alien
nest to save Newt they'll fight for
their lives and Ripley Newt and Hicks
they all get out of there alive because
they've earned it and in the beginning
of the third movie two out of the three
of them are dead just in the intro I
kind of felt like that was the case here
thor ragnarok you know you have all
those monologues about how as god is
into place as god is her people as god
will live on with her people know
whether Asgard is a place or the people
Asgard is dead now getting everybody on
the ship oh we gotta get the survivors
out of here so Asgard can live only to
die in the beginning of the next movie I
don't know I just I just never liked
that kind of storytelling if I give this
movie a pass for it I have to give alien
3 a pass for it and that's just not in
my genetic makeup to do so not the Alien
franchise doesn't get a pass neither
does this one still a great intro for
Thanos nobody chokes out Loki and snaps
his neck in front of Thor and we all
lament the war criminal Loki the event
of the first Avengers movie was on TV
this weekend I was like man Loki is a
dick but now we feel bad for him but we
can't help it so where does get an I he
gets like another eye instead of an
eyepatch which I personally like Thor
with the eyepatch just like pick a side
keep his eye or give him an eyepatch
don't make him lose an eye only to give
them a new eye
I'm saying when you do things to
characters and they lose an eye per se
give them an eyepatch and have that be
the thing that sticks with them now for
many movies if you give them an eye
immediately you have to wonder like
why'd you even lose the eye in the first
place you're just back to where you
started with an eye I like the
collectors base scene they go in there
everything's fine Thanos is there then
Gamora stab stano's and then it all just
wipes away and you see everything they
were just burning which means the
collectors probably dead what are we not
getting it Howard the Duck moving out
Howard the Duck is Howard the fuck'd if
he was there but it's another scene
where it shows how powerful that
gauntlet makes Thanos he turns Drax into
what blocks like just kind of makes him
fall apart but I think he's been fan of
sleaze Drax goes back to normal and I
wouldn't make him go back to normal that
would be it birthday no so he tracks
your that forever in a world where you
can turn lasers into bubbles I would
turn Drax into a bubble and just pop
them just your dad spider-man's iron
spider suit actually does have the iron
spider arms I thought that was cool
would have blown my mind if I saw for
the first time on screen but I didn't
saw it on the hot toys [ __ ] one of the
missions is Thor has to go
get his weapon he has to go get his
weapon from the guy who actually made
the Infinity Gauntlet for Thanos who is
Peter Dinklage playing a giant dwarf
which I think I'm remembering this right
did I see Thor take the power of a dying
star to his chest like when he was in
that ring and he was balancing it out
did the beam go through him is the
nyquil making that fuzzy like am I
remembering that correctly because of
Thor took that [ __ ] to his chest he is
officially the most broken thing in the
world in the universe really what else
did his nuke proof anos with all the
Infinity stones took an axe to the chest
and it really hurt him Thor took a dying
start of the chest and it hurt him
banished the Lord greater than Thanos I
did like the scene where Thanos goes
with Gamora to that place where the
Infinity stone is that she's hidden
partly because they had Red Skull there
we get to see what happened to Red Skull
who straight up alright who didn't think
Skeletor do you think sky baskets are my
own questions like how have you eaten
here what what's the food like but he
has to sacrifice what he cares about I
was working more on this one I was
longer you don't care about anything
you're [ __ ] it's really it's kind of
it that's the kind of puzzle that's like
a Horcrux puzzle when Thanos squeaked to
tear I was like oh no he gives a [ __ ] oh
no you're dead which right that I'm
gonna try to break this one down for
gamora's death the impact for me was the
fact that Thanos had to kill his
daughter who he apparently cared deeply
about the impact was not Gamora died the
impact was not star-lords girlfriend
died here's the guardians of the galaxy
angle doesn't hit me as much as the fan
hose angle does maybe I'm cold to it
because I feel like star-lord loved
Gamora more than Kimura apparently loves
star-lord he's showing it more than she
did anyway so now that she's gone I'm
like don't worry star-lord next time
you'll find someone who loves you at the
level you love them it'll be equal the
lack of Hulk bums me out like the Hulk
was having performance issues Hulk just
couldn't come out to play today it's
fines common problem one in five
actually there was Hulk Buster action
which in the trailer it showed the Hulk
switched the Hulk out with Hulk Buster
that's actually what happened
my favorite fight in the movie is the
fan oohs versus Iron Man spider-man star
Lord mantis I was just a great fight in
that scene where Thanos so uses the
gauntlet he just goes kaboom you see the
moon go good jobs like get the [ __ ] out
of here I thought he was bringing the
moon down and everybody I mean granted
he just
basically took chunks of the moon had
meteorites come down those great scene
they almost got it to have him
hypnotized they're trying to take the
gauntlet off star-lord learns that
Gamora is dead and then he just flips
out and star-lord just loses his [ __ ]
starts punching Thanos like I understand
you're gonna be paved why don't you get
the thing off of his arm then shoot him
in the face I mean almost good at off
the Infinity Gauntlet literally comes
off and he grabs just the end of it and
it gets it back on he just beats
everyone down I like when Thanos had his
moment with stocker he's like I respect
you start after this is done half of
humanity will still be around I hope
they remember you it's a big deal and it
shows depth when an opponent can look at
his opponent and be like nah but I do
respect you I do like dr. Strange's
response he saw every outcome he saw
millions of outcomes he's like there's
one where we survive and you can kind of
assess it's the one where he gave him
the stone I imagine in every scenario
where they fought him they died and he
got the stone anyway but if strange gave
Thanos the stone they would live but
half of them would still disappear but I
imagine he knew that Tony Stark would
not do severe so basically all that was
just to save Tony Stark's life that was
the one thing that could change in that
scenario that was a smooth move cuz that
strange said we're in the endgame got to
accept the reality of your situation
the scene where Thanos gets the mine
stone was actually perverse I loved it
but it was perverse because I knew
someone would reverse time to bring
someone back to life I thought Doctor
Strange is gonna do that to save I don't
know Captain America's life or something
I did not think Scarlet Witch was going
to kill the man she loves vision and
then Thanos was gonna come reversed time
undo it so we can just rip the stone out
of his head anyway so Scarlet Witch can
go ahead and feel that grave for nothing
then Thor's axe comes out of nowhere
just lands of the Thanos I guess that's
how we had to happen guy has all the
stones so you're gonna have to snipe him
from like a mile away which essentially
is what happens but it says you should
have aim for my head BAM what did you do
I mean it his gauntlet looks messed up
too it looks fry it still works though
cuz he conjured a portal then everyone
starts disappearing they start turning
into ash or dust or installation foam or
whatever they turn into well not
everyone half the people first ones
Bucky he just gone I don't have my phone
with me so I don't know exactly all
right let's try to try to remember
Doctor Strange I really was one of them
spider-man that won't crush me because
he's a kid it was that Tony Stark
feeling responsible Tony Stark should
have been like this actually isn't my
fault if you were on earth odds are it's
still a coin flip whether or not you die
there anyway or disappear whatever is
happening Oh King to Chawla
Black Panther he disappeared I remember
that [ __ ] cuz I was like okay so I don't
think this is actually a permanent black
panther was well-received by critics
well received by the audience and
crushed in the box-office I mean you
tell me they're just gonna vaporize the
star No
so they're coming back somehow someway
is actually if we wanted to start
speculating and doing theories there so
what's the internet without speculation
in a world of multiverse there would be
any infinite number of infinite
possibilities of people who did or did
not disappear in this 5050 coin flip of
half the people disappear but let's just
say it's divided among two universes
what if the ones we saw disappear in
their universe saw everyone else does a
bear maybe it's their way of dividing
the MCU being like all right so not
everything has to be linked now would
that be neat if Black Panther 2 starts
out and is to chala and Bucky not
disappearing seeing Captain America
disappear or something matter they're
just gonna bring him back somehow that
is they're just gone but we'll see what
happens the most important thing to
remember from this movie is and this is
something that hit me when I was driving
home from the screening this is truly
fan OSes movie it shouldn't be called
Avengers anything do should be called
Thanos infinity war if you really see it
as this guy who is trying his best to
bring balance to the universe and you
see the Avengers as this rabble of
super-powered militia trying to stop him
I think you'll see this movie at the
most fulfilling angle the most
fulfilling spectrum and that's a neat
twist on the superhero genre right there
the post-credits scene of which this
movie has one of is Nick Fury an agent
like you think of her name agent hottie
you can I still color that in 2018
nyquil anyhow they're in a car and then
there's a car accident that happens I
get out and look in the car there's no
one in it and a helicopter crashes and
it's actually I like the fact that it
showed that in a world where half the
people are disappearing there's gonna be
a lot of helicopters that come down a
lot of vehicle accidents even they're
gonna die as a result of people
disappearing so it's not just half the
populations couldn't go away half the
population and deaths as a result of
that half the population then agent
hottie disappears and the Nick Fury is
sending a text on this really analog
piece of tech and then of course him
disappearing censors in from saying
the [ __ ] as he disappears and it lands
on the ground and she goes captain
Marvel's logo and then that said he was
texting Captain Marvel but you do wonder
is it really half of the people in the
universe of disappear imagine is not
compartmentalized to earth because you
know we saw the Mantis disappeared so
are there really beings on the other
side of the known universe just half the
population disappeared if Thanos get to
choose who disappears because if I were
him dude I'd be like all right half the
population but in that half the
population 100% of the Avengers are just
gonna disappear oh it's just random
chance
in which case none of the Avengers gonna
disappear point is if nyquil does not
betray me
Thor took a son to the chest and that
does indeed make him mighty I saw
Avengers infinity war have you seen it
what did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and
since I am literally actually the last
person on YouTube to get their Avengers
infinity war spoiler video up you can
send this around to you know people
who's seen the movie I'd appreciate that
love it help me I have [ __ ] pathogens
ice or just hamstringing my youtube
channel and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see any more
[Music]